ils sont artistes écrivains philosophes
ou encore journalistes qui ont décidé
dans une lettre adressée au président de
la république ait sayed de s'exprimer
sur la situation du pays et de lui
apporter leur soutien
la plupart ont connu une époque où en
tunisie la liberté d'expression était
muselée par le pouvoir en place
la révolution de 2011 a permis au peuple
tunisien de retrouver sa souveraineté
ces intellectuels dénoncent donc
l'islamisme politique les crises
partisane la corruption et l'ingérence
étrangère un frein selon eux à la
transition démocratique a entamé le pays
écoutez à ce sujet moncef ben mrad
journaliste écrivain est signataire de
la lettre
l'objectif de cette lettre c'est c'est
de dire que les intellectuels sens là
qu'il vend qu'ils appuient ce qui s'est
passé ce n'est pas un goal paix comme le
disent les sud-américains a pas du tout
ça n'a rien à voir avec un goal paix
parce qu'ils n'en avaient un état
mafieux un état obscurantistes un état
pro terrorise et à ce moment si les
décisions prises pour des sous pour
geler provisoirement pendant un mois à
l'assemblée nationale et pour s'attaquer
aux gros pente de de l'affairisme de la
corruption etc
on ne pouvait qu'être d'accord on ne
pouvait pas avoir une autre solution
mais ceci dit on a affirmé et confirmé
notre soutien total des libertés et
réaffirmé notre vigilance futur pour
tout ce qui pourrait toucher la liberté
d'autrui c'est clair dans cette lettre
ouverte
ils dressent leurs bilans de la décennie
passée l'effondrement de l'économie
l'obsolescence du système de santé
l'effondrement de l'éducation et la
fuite des cerveaux
sans oublier de pointer du doigt un
système judiciaire sous la coupe du
parti ennahda si ces intellectuels
soutiennent l'action du président il a
su rester vigilant pour contribuer à
protéger les libertés dans ce pays qu'il
rêve libre démocratique et moderne